ayant est en train de lui travailler ses
beaux cheveux à ce moment-là duranton
waber pourquoi géré l'affairé pas
oh
est ce silence d'une importante avait
partie du jeu ne soit trop tard je le
joue et leon
je partirai ont tout à l'heure 12 mois a
dit oui lui sourit le micron monsieur
hydro ne vient d'être blessé
park est apparu chez dunlop je ne sais
pas alors nous allons me luxe yves jégo
demande infiniment pardon dit oui je n'y
va plus rien je n'ai rien à l'oeil mais
l'on m'a cassé mes lunettes
par conséquent nous allons voir comment
nous allons faire le tir à la corde
malheureusement sans lunettes je ne peux
rien faire on va essayer d'y parer par
conséquent nous allons improvisé mais
malheureusement je n'ai plus tout à fait
tous mes moyens
m
si nous tous les cas mon âge sont les
risques du métier léo estime entendez on
l'est ont rendez-vous les eaux ici
carcassonne apple taxes ici captatio
nabil dax je voudrais que les on me
répondre léon zitrone répondez moi ici
je vous appelle de carcassonne hannut à
lui que monsieur il prône est en train
de se faire soigner
oui j'ai bien compris mais est-ce que
nous pouvons poursuivre les messieurs ce
qui n'est pas bliss et non il n'y a rien
non attendez un club n'est pas grave
quand et ferrals ce n'est pas grave dit
luc se poursuit dès l'émission oui oui
leo je vous demande pardon dit non ils
n'ont pas non plus je voudrais aussi
rassurer des miens qui sont devant leur
écran et leur dire que finalement en
dehors du fait qu'on m'a cassé mes
lunettes et que je n'y vois bien tout va
bien mais c'est claude savary qui
vraisemblablement
je savais que madame molinier qui est
venu là soir elle va finir par le
regretter
parce que non mais je vous comprends
bien mais pas de chance on arrières audy
à chaque émission alors si lors s'il
vous plaît voilà c'est ce qu'on dit à
chaque échange et moi on pourrait
peut-être dire des choses concrètes et
on va demander à l'espace le front du
feu danse originale et on le sort de
monsieur besoin alors nous allons on va
revenir je regrette que les que l'état
jc mais amener des énergumènes avec eux
et je vais vous faire écouter quand tu
vois la regarder d'accord laissez-le l'a
envoyé frédéric deux femmes et couper
l'image parce que c'est vraiment pas
plaisant
ouais mais tu es le le générique de fin
avec la chanson de dia colombo
voilà mettez la chanson douce iacono et
couper l'antenne en coupe l'antenne et
je m'exclus non pas les téléspectateurs
voilà c'est parti 17 heures 39 minutes
et 50 secondes bonsoir à tous
vous rentrez du bio
au hockey bon ça y est c'est vrai bien
rendre c'est la règle
voilà la preuve que c'est un vrai direct
et la preuve que l'on atteint invités
qu'il y a de l'humour moi au moins je
suis je suis en bonne je suis un pascal
je suis en bonne compagnie avec le
président elkabbach qui a eu droit aussi
oui j'ai pu me donner un oui on va le
message pascal ce qu'on peut se dire aux
uns ce qu'on peut dire aussi c'est que
c'est le signe d'une véritable
reconnaissance médiatique au togo voilà
voilà voilà
regarde vers les versants réunissant
médecins une sandrine voilà vous allez
viens on va faire ça en direct à les y
voilà bonsoir à tous en tout cas merci
pour votre accueil
c'était pas moi et lui on n'avait pas
prévu de démarrer les missions comme ça
mais où est la caméra là la caméra elle
est juste ici le petit écran droit
toujours et il est là je disais donc que
vous rentrez du boulot pour en fait les
cours on va passer 35 minutes comme
chaque soir en compagnie d'un pascal
sevran est ce qu'on a là quelques
combats mais récents donnent je voudrais
dire deux choses
oui j'ai été piégé cette semaine par
surprise surprise je viens d'être piégés
par taisions belge hélas les addicts
avec moi m'ont dit j'ai vraiment les
billets en belgique et c'est vrai je
suis toujours bien reçus et anne mes
amis m'a dit fais gaffe parce que c'est
il ya il ya le mec avec les tartes à la
crème
quand je lis pas trois fois dans la même
semaine et bien c'est complètement
réussi sur ce cas on leur a quand même
un peu plus prévoir bref temps
maintenant pour la chemise là oui j'ai
engueulé après parce que je vais faire
une telle illusion tout à l'heure je
vais essayer de changer le temps que
l'on travaille un peu mieux on va vous
dire la vérité
pascal est grande de ceux qui sont
fermés mais on est célèbre on on avait
imaginé que nos amis en tarte rohr
puisse peut-être sévir durant cette
semaine on avait tous les mois on avait
pris quelques dispositions mais le
problème c'est qu'ils deviennent très
très professionnel vous savez que notre
amie hélène et bien a subi les foudres
des lanceurs c'est une scène carrément
sur la scène dont vraiment y'a rien à
chiens courants ces gens là je prends
soin je prends ça comme un hommage
formidable à malte or y était c'est ce
que je lui avais dit le mot
ce qui m'ennuie le plus c'est que je
déteste sa crème chantilly ou picoler
tous en train de regarder la hémoise
suis sur mon joint vous allez dire à
allah dégueulasse à cros dégueulasse
alors que c'est moi une drogue ce que
vous êtes en train de prendre
j'ai pas de la publicité pour la 6e rang
perdues mans ça me fait pas du tout
parler de drogue parce que j'en ai rien
à faire mais ce qui ne me plaît pas
c'est la notion policière
ces différentes annonces médical travaux
vous êtes bâillonnés police et
simplement voulu dire qu'effectivement
c'est un pan ou les pm vivre mais moi
aussi j'ai envie d'y retourner
je vous dirais par exemple on voit la
situation commençait par lancelot est
terminée par barge avait je crois qu'il
y avait il n'y avait pas d' attaque
témoin pour l'instant j'ai le temps de
cette conversation je vous dirais
carrément que cette conversation me
paraît le monde n est qu elle m'emmerde
vraiment merdé j'ai envie de changer le
ton j'ai envie de détendre tout ça on
aime à le dire ils ont changé leur oui
s'il a enfin su là enfin vous pouvez
regarder quelqu'un qui s'exprime
naturellement merde quoi
égouttez on est à la télé française on
peut dire merde on peut dire fais chier
[__] de moine et tout montrer sans lui
si vous voulez vous montrerons qu'il
sert terry spectacle
bien donc voici le film de monsieur
maurice claval monsieur mon esclave elle
est ce que vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter à votre film
j'ai beaucoup de choses a ajouté à mon
film tout de suite tout de suite je
m'adresse au public et je lui dis ceci
je viens de rédiger la déclaration à
l'instant le film que vous venez de voir
a été censuré par la télévision
française
peu importe qu'il était est censuré d'un
mot une phrase d'une séquence d'un tiers
des trois quarts d'un centième c'est le
principe même de la censure qui était
pouvant table abominable et invivable en
tout cas pour ma part je n'ai jamais pu
vivre ni écrire ni parler sous le régime
de la censure on m'a prévenu dans
l'après midi de cette coupure comme mon
père et de cette chose inouïe et j'ai
élevé une protestation solennelle mais
cette chose inouïe j'attendais de la
voir pour le croire
je les ai vus en conséquence je viens de
prendre la décision suivante je ne
saurais prendre part un débat qui
commence sous le régime de l'instant sur
quelle qu'en soit la victime moi ou
monsieur royer il soit bien entendu
monsieur royer je ne me dérobe pas à une
confrontation entre nous sur le problème
des moeurs et de la culpabilité de la
société je vous propose de le reprendre
sur n'importe quelle chaîne de radio
libre s'il en existe et si évidemment
vous renoncez à la censure dont vous
constatez ici le désastre
quant au peuple français auquel je viens
très modestement de lancer un appel au
soulèvement de la vie contre ces espèces
de morts que sont la censure et autres
fascisme jaunes en moins modestement lui
donner rendez-vous pour bientôt dans la
liberté pour la liberté
messieurs les censeurs bonsoir
je crie au voleur la parole est le
dernier parce que leur apprennent
gaillard était flame j'aime vous
entendre dire que vous êtes là pour
défendre le capitalisme
si vous êtes là pour défendre le
capitalisme anne gaillard je n'aime pas
dit que j'étais là pour défendre ces
gars là ne ne fait pas la même chose que
madame que je n'ai pas dit que j'étais
là pour défendre le capitaliste j'ai
dirigé technique on ne peut même pas
parler avec vous j'ai été invité à cette
émission proposée question ne peut même
pas les poser c'est pas votre émission
pour une fois mais il ne dit pas des
choses fausses mais d'une manière
autonome
on ne peut même pas avec vous en
reprenant des termes justes et pas des
termes forts laissez-moi aller jusqu'au
bout vous répondrais anne gaillard votre
métier n'est pas d'empêcher les gens
vous interviewez de parler anne gaillard
vous interview ne sont pas des
interviews ce sont des interrogatoires
anne gaillard vous vous donnez le droit
d'accuser et vous ne laissez pas vous
accusez le droit de vous répondre
anne gaillard vous faites du terrorisme
technique le gaillard vous je déjeune
d'arc
vous êtes l'éclair de france inter anne
gaillard vous voulez bien mater monsieur
ennjimi après cible écoutez vous ai pas
honte de tuân gaillard les dés sont
jetés
les ai dit vous inviter des gens sur
avec votre entourage pour qu'il ne
puisse même pas se défendre
je ne peux même pas aller au bout de mon
exposé et d'ailleurs seront sous les
termes annoncés le concile également de
votre ennemi ce lotissement à madaya
énonce clairement qu'au jeu mais non ce
parfait tout un perdant ou gagnant je
pense avoir été parfaitement compris ce
n'est pas votre cas jamais coupé le
micro jeu c'est de la diffamation ce que
vous nécessaire jamais je n'ai coupé un
micro madame coupe je vous interdis
cette semaine
nous n'allons tout de même pas faire la
psychanalyste de cette dame et ap
coupées et les écarter non chère madame
je n'ai non je vous lis recettes nous
les jounaux madame je suis absolument
désolé je refuse clown et je n'ai jamais
coupé un micro et puis pour couper un
micro c'est pas moi qui peux couper le
micro c'est l'équipe technique et c'est
l'équipe de france inter que vous menez
d'insultés et toute l'équipe technique
et
réalisateur et tous les gens qui sont le
tout est de la ville grâce tous venez de
dire madame
deuxième constatation il ya 90% de
compte 10% deux frères mes frères mais
chez les femmes c'est gratiné j'ai
rencontré d esprit citoyen chez les
femmes mais 1% lien ramassis de kaunas
je ne te dis que ça c'est comme des
choses si vous voulez me voir je sois
pas pleinement precious haute et nous
passions pour des dégueulasse parce que
de temps en temps quelqu'un quand elle
nous en viendrons au hockey ciao
au revoir
ok finalement il n'y a pas tellement la
bouteille américains voulaient l'emmener
là voilà monsieur qu'il fallait mettre
un fond la griffe à 2002 où il a porté
ses bouteilles l'annoncé boutin pour qui
c'était juste et la télévision qu'il
ignore la porte lui même ses beaux
parents pour apporter son et moi j'avais
simplement frank-j discuter avec vous
avec vous mais moi on a varié pas comme
ça vous arrive on n'en parle jamais
arrivé par vous mettre dans votre petite
tête que moi aussi j'ai un cerveau et à
c'est un mot qui est capable de
raisonner de réfléchir et formuler des
propositions et des appréciations la
touche fut comble je ne suis pas obligé
d'aller chez je devais pas à prendre les
espaces et aller à saint gély dans ma
petite tête j'en conviens je vais à
l'étranger je discute j'écoute et cetera
mais je suis quand même je sais je suis
peut-être qu'un ouvrière à mes yeux mais
je suis un militant ouvrier qui avec mes
camarades intellectuelle dans son parti
est capable de procéder à des analyses
qui tiennent debout
d'ailleurs dire sans vous être contre
j'adore ces deux brochures sait les
rapports qui gonâve que j'ai fait au
congrès et la résolution vous avez vous
ça a été fait au mois date au mois de
mars avril ça généreux et bien vous
verrez c'est la justification de ce qui
se passe maintenant
permettez je voudrais dire que limité à
dire avant la fin d'émission sparta pour
monsieur mitterrand parce que moi
j'avais pris plein de monde en venant
dans votre version non je n'aurai pas le
temps je le sais déjà j'ai pas le temps
j'ai juste le temps de mettre en colère
je commence maintenant non c'est le
système de la formation française qui
fait comme ça j'aurai le temps une
minute de m'énerver juste de m'énerver
de paraître pour un petit nerveux un
petit jeune de [__] la pagaille
partout
je préfère m'en aller tout de suite si
j'avais su je dois bien dire j'aurais
dormi beaucoup plus tard l'iran
souhaitées votre présence dans la voie
inverse où la radio pour parler des
problèmes de la jeunesse je pense que
nous aurons eu tort nous aurions eu le
temps d'en parler s'était refait n'ont
pas de chance y aura les envies au
dessus et c'était pas de chansons dont
il était question je vous en prie parler
pendant 10 minutes au moins de la sphère
georges marchais dont tout le monde se
fout strictement je vous soutiens que la
jeunesse française se fout strictement
de ce que monsieur marché faisait
pendant la guerre sale des complètement
égal ces intérêts seraient plus la
jeunesse de savoir ce qui se passe et
comment le parti communiste en caisse de
l'argent pour le dépenser après
notamment la mairie de bagnolet
s'intéresserait mieux de savoir comment
gaston defferre dirige sa mairie
socialiste qui n'est pas un modèle de
société à marseille s'intéresserait plus
de savoir les jeunes français comment
monsieur raymond barre qui est arrivé il
ya cinq ans ou quatre ans je ne sais
plus combien de temps a dit que les
salaires ne seraient pas diminué mais
qui à augmenter les cotisations de
sécurité sociale c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant que tout ce que vous
racontez georges marchais on s'en fout
de georges marchais il faut le savoir de
ce qui faisait pendant la guerre ça nous
est complètement égal le problème de
drogue de la façon dont on le traite les
ministres français on s'en fout il n'y a
jamais un jeune ministre delà de la
jeunesse en france y en a jamais eu et
c'est tous des vieux
regardez monsieur soissons enfin vous
n'allez pas me dire que c'était un homme
représentatif de la jeunesse regarder
comment je suis habillé ils sont plus
souvent billets com - les jeunes que
comme monsieur soissons il faut quand
même pas rêver
tout ça ce sont des vétilles j'ai encore
pris bonne note au fur à mesure que vous
parlez ce que je voudrais savoir ce qui
m'a intéressé c'est de savoir à qui les
travailleurs immigrés paye un loyer qui
paye
on a vu tout à l'heure des gens qui
disaient on paye 700 francs par mois moi
je voudrais savoir qu'ils encaissent de
l'argent pour louer des poubelles pareil
c'est ça que je voudrais qu'on me dise
c'est pas de savoir comment on peut
faire pour changer je voudrais qu'ils
osent tout les mois demandés 700 francs
les travailleurs immigrés pour vivre
dans des poubelles dans des taudis
ça c'est ça que je voudrais qu'on
m'explique pas ce que moi je ne le sais
pas c'est pas la force et la formation
qui me dit je voudrais savoir pourquoi
monsieur boulin était suicidé ou s'est
suicidé
ne saura jamais pourquoi monsieur
fontana l'itc signé pourquoi la sphère
le brevet n'a jamais été éclairés
pourquoi le juge renaud on s'est pas ni
pourquoi ni comment il a été assassiné
j'en ai d'autres la seule chose que je
peux vous dire monsieur mitterrand jean
vous fait de vous avoir parce que je
suis fier d'être là je peux vous le dire
on s'en aperçoit peut-être pas vous
pouvez pas imaginer ce que c'est pour un
jeune d'avoir la possibilité de parler
une minute c'est pour ça que j'avais
peur de ne pas pouvoir parler parce que
ça n'arrive jamais faut bien se mettre
ça dans la tête
non ça n'arrête jamais regardé
l'émission cas hier soir sur antenne 2
les dossiers de l'écran
enfin vous n'allez pas me dire que les
mots les maux qui étaient concernés par
contre j'ai vraiment la chance et le
lien je sais on est obligé goûter vous
exagérez l'information je suis obligé de
l'expérience mais moi je pour résumer je
la résume à ma manière que j'essaie de
le lire rapidement mes notes
ce que je vous donnais en tout cas c'est
généralement c'est un avertissement j'ai
peut-être du culot de faire ça je suis
obligé de le faire comme ça parce que je
dois faire vite
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
jeunesse désespère elle est profondément
profondément désespéré parce qu'elle n'a
plus d'appuis elle ne croit plus en la
politique française et moi je pense qu'à
la règle générale en résumant un peu
bien raison ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que le désespoir et mobilisateur
et que lorsqu'il devient mobilisateur il
est dangereux et que ça entraîne le
terrorisme la bande à baader et des
choses comme ça et ça il faut que les
grandes personnes qui dirigent le monde
soit prévenu que les jeunes vont finir
par virer du mauvais côté parce qu'ils
n'auront plus d'autre solution
voilà je vous remercie le voir et je
m'appelle je vais pas s il vous plaît à
je crois que nous avons je crois que
monsieur pierre debray qui est le mari
de madame sabran bon et bien terminée
quand même de surgir pour donner son
avis le bras une assemblée de port de
grâce est en train de nous traiter
ridicule aucun n'était qu'à l'interné
monsieur pierre debray madame ça bronze
c'est tout à fait normal que vous
réagissiez vous avez réagi devant elle
quand on est un drama c'était moi j'ai
un droit de répondre je souffre elle est
alors alors totalement les producteurs
des stocks cassé
françois chalais terminé on appelle svp
r3 on regarde notre sang froid on reste
entre nous était avec ceux qui nous
regardent
je crois que l'uniforme est une garantie
d'égalité un effet quand on est en civil
les embauches les autres plus les autres
un peu moins exacts sont extrêmement
techniques comme tout le monde est moche
ça c'est vrai vous quand vous voterez
comme ça veut dire du cochon avait
changé je défends cohn-bendit maire
d'aiguefonde qui se réveille elle est
facile à vendre que ça vient du bas là
ça vient d'une terreur ça vient de ma
loisirs général et polkas oui pour moi
j'aime pas choquant ça le premier but
pour être choqués mais je voyais très
grosse il ya tout un choc pour moi je
vais pas choqué non j'ai rien dit pour
les stocks
tarifs 10 tarif believe quotidien pour
la ville hantée même pas capable tu veux
te disent qu'elles sont des alcools etc
ferrari p4
cela dit la chambre bertrand et j'ai
tendresse et admiration un art majeur
devant une initiation pas un art mineur
comme ce que les canards économies que
nous faisons nous mais quel est ce pour
le surréalisme qui vous avez rien mais
dans une chanson mais si vous mais qui
si elle venait annoncer des arts qui te
parle
mais en quoi est ce que ces mineurs une
chanson sans qu ils s'exonèrent 6 me
gardner situera que la peinture il n'a
pas besoin d'initiation de cabourg la
chanson caps d'initiation pour la pâte
pour les arts majeurs larchitecture la
peinture et la musique classique et à
littérature et la poésie la poésie s'il
te plaît ne faisons pas de la poésie
non il n'ya pas d'art mineur et ce n'est
pas la peine c'est la chanson faisant ce
mineur sinon je ne serais pas là tu peux
tout est important même la cuisine soeur
prendre du pognon ou sur le pauvre serge
gainsbourg toutes vos chansons qu'on
tirait que ce sont des choses mineures
alors absolument c'est vrai sauf
certaines qui ont frôlé c'est la
première fois de ma vie c'est pas la
première fois que je m'engage parce que
j'ai jamais mis mes idées dans ma poche
il ne sait peut-être ta gueule ta gueule
ta gueule c'est un peu un peu un poète
qui est descendu de salut
non non si tu veux c'est pas ça c'est
que c'est que qu'est ce que je voulais
dire qu'est ce que j'étais en train de
dire la cantine entendu d'exiger les
limites le droit de dire des trucs
l'étoile n'a pas droit non
si tu veux ce que ce que
les aïeuls ouais et je peux le redire
encore
fête du livre du grand soir je crois pas
cette espèce de déversement de hargne de
bill et de haine je crois que le monde
va grosso modo vers quelque chose qui
s'appelle la vie nc je pense qu'en
payant c'est notre planète que voudrait
seulement s'instaure la planète mais
calendrier chacun de retrouver ses
parents
est ce que monsieur strauss j'entends
voix elle ce stock vous êtes haineux et
moi je peux vous dire que moi l'avenir
il l'a été je pense que le grand message
que j'ai envie de donner à l'avenir
c'est un message d'amour parce que moi
j'ai trois enfants et ils vont vivre
cela et vous vous avez simplement un
tombereau de haine et d'injures à
déverser je vous le connaissez pas vous
m'avez agressé vous savez pas qui je
suis et vous ne traitez d'agents de la
cia mais c'est incroyable vous êtes
haineux et ceci est absolument être
vraiment ne comprends pas que vous soyez
à ce point ton bureau comme ça de haine
noah et vous pas réellement et vous par
les allemands avec un espèce de haine
qui est incroyable et vraiment je suis
hors de moi donc vous vivez à londres
vous êtes un petit peu rebelle ça vous
fait de la musique oblige et des rockers
la mairie vous rentrez en amérique de
toute urgence parce que votre père a été
arrêté pour fraude à l'assurance ah oui
c'est vrai effectivement mon père a
passé huit ans en prison voilà oui j'ai
perdu mon père pendant huit ans
comment vous plaît aujourd'hui faire
lippi public culpabiliser bertrand
cantat c'est ça que j'essaye de
comprendre les effets un livre que
justement une espèce de frontières
cuisante entre la vision et jeu se met
dans la peau de quelqu'un qui pour moi
qui pour moi mais c'est complètement ma
profession a voulu simple un jour fait
une erreur la faute irréparable la
choses impardonnables et la tuer et
d'autres personnes et celle de très
minutieusement tous les jours ce sont
des tortures ont mieux su et sait cela
donc effectivement que je veux vraiment
dénoncer les autres après tout ça n'est
pas du tout mon problème et quentin
compte tout à fait
je me suis dit bertrand cantat mais bien
sûr que c'est sa faute
j'ai commencé j'ai entamé une
correspondance avec lui je voulais
savoir s'il en était je faisais lettre
bouleversante de ce type il s'en sortira
jamais jamais il a été voir ta femme qui
venait d'accoucher de sa fille alice
alors qu'il était avec marie il était
fou amoureux de marie dont le thème de
mon livre c'est l'amour passion et
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait qu'est ce qui se
passe avec bon le début de ma
correspondance avec constat qui a été
arrêté après digne parce qu'après je
crois qu'il est trop malade pour
correspondre avec qui que ce soit et
nous avions écrit récemment voté oui bah
c'est pas si fort pour préparer un
nouveau disque avec son groupe
ça valait bien que la gale et ben c'est
pas bien sûr muriel ça veut dire qu'ils
arrivent à vivre et on lui a volé son
amour il a tué bien sûr que l'or
continue parce qu'à mon sens aucun corps
et très présente au gabon il a tué
justement dans un geste complètement
honte et dans un geste comme maintenant
posséder avec des succès en asie avec
des substances 36 coutancie facture 36
coup absolument le visage décomposé
comme pour un accident de moto avec des
brûlures aux jambes et aux cuisses comme
quelqu'un qu'on a traîné pour te mettre
dans le lit avec un appel au frère de
marie à qu'il ne dit pas ce qui s'est
passé qui dit que marie ève locaux car
dira simplement que l'on veut remettre à
plus tard le premier jour de tournage
d'après était une femme qui meurt
doucement d'hémorragie inter c'est
effectivement ce que je dis elle est
morte dans une espèce de rêve de corps
humains et de non conversion qui sait
comment il l'a tapée et il est le seul à
le savoir
excusez moi c'est vrai que quand quand
on lit vos bouquins on voit pas ça c'est
à dire qu'on a l'impression qu'il donne
un coup qui s'emporte il n'ya pas les 36
coup y'a pas les 35 ou en effet car je
n'avais pas la connaissant leurs 36 qu
on joue simplement les lettres de tandt
a oui les lettres de compta vous savez
ce qu'est vraiment un pervers
narcissique c'est quelqu'un qui sait
manipuler
un ordre et nord et ce sont des joueurs
de claquettes
moi je pense que quand quelqu'un
classerait mon temps à lire le droit
ville de vilnius lituanien pour
comprendre qu'en effet les substances
alcooliques et et illicites sont
absolument des faits aggravants dans le
droit lituanien et pas dans le droit
français parce que c'est laissé à
logements des juges
je regrette je dis c'est très très clair
parce que moi aussi j'ai étudié tout ça
c'était très important pour moi et que
donc petit à petit la déposition de
bertrand cantat parce que c'est ça les
actes c'est qu'est-ce qu'il a déposée et
comment il a changé de dépositions entre
le moment où il a été arrêté ou nous
avons eu des informations des médecins
de vilnius qui ont dit qu'ils avaient
pris tous les deux des substances et
tous les deux avaient bu et que quand il
a vu que dans le droit lituanien ce
n'est même pas moi qui le dit c'est
libération il a changé complètement son
discours pour dire qu'il était le mari
avait été la seule à avoir dû avoir
fumer des pétards
excusez moi qu'un moment et qu'à un
moment elle était parti tout seul
absolument prendre soi disant des choses
dans les toilettes
ça a été pas dit au début et ce sont des
choses qui ont été rajoutés au fur et à
mesure - chez lui tout le procès j'ai vu
un bertrand cantat se mettre au courant
des lois et petit à petit me distrait
des positions et préparer sa défense
ce que je comprends très très bien parce
que chacun à son esprit reptilien et il
faut qu'on survivent maintenant kristina
rady c'est la même chose quand elle est
arrivée elle a raconté les violences
qu'elle avait subi avec bertrand cantat
dont elle s'est rétractée tout de suite
après quand elle a vu que tu est à la
rue
elle a cru descendre ses enfants moi je
ne crois pas qu'on descend ses enfants
contre le mensonge
moi ce que je sais c'est que marie est
morte avec un visage qui étaient
détruits comme après un accident de moto
eu à 120 à l'heure et ce sont les mots
même des médecins bien à l'oral lui
aussi très claire d'avancer un petit peu
vous muriel non mais j'essaye de
comprendre comment vous
alors si vous avez subi comment vous
pouvez défendre encore quand elle est et
vous dit en parlant de votre joueur la
foule bertrand cantat revendre votre
jules vous dit que vous l'avez pardonner
tout simplement parce que vous ne pouvez
pas imaginer la vie sans lui vous dit
vivre sans lui c'est la mort vivre avec
lui c'est la mort mais peut-être aussi
la vie vous dit
la seule façon qu'il aurait de me tuer
actuellement serait de me quitter
donc finalement vous préférez rester
avec quelqu'un qui est susceptible de
vous frapper que d'être quitté par cette
personne c'est ça que j'essaie de
comprendre de me frapper c'est quelqu'un
qui est très malade dont je voudrais
effectivement obtenir quelque chose de
mieux et une rédemption pour lui qu'il
aille mieux inscrire rien qui supporte
mal donc je ne peux pas quitter
quelqu'un qui se porte mal quand ils me
fassent pour l'instant je suis bien
incapable en ailier quelque part une
saison c'est probablement quelque chose
d'assez noble c'est peut-être par là on
serait peut-être quelque part par l'âme
et je ne peux pas moi vivre sans passion
je suis désolé je ne suis pas là à dire
on a frappés on n'a pas faim oui bien
sûr ah si le jour où on m'a vraiment où
cet homme pris par une crise de démence
en était une effectivement commencé à
sortir des couteaux puis des pierres à
vouloir me très bien sûr que je vous
conseille des cours de karaté accéléré
vous mon père que comme aïda si vous
voulez vous serez au même temps au même
niveau
parce que le problème entre un insolent
avec les quelques acquis bars et les
volets combat pour faire le couple sait
qu'on est au même niveau on est à oman
air l'explication le débiteur qui
n'écrit pas et qui tu es quelqu'un qui
avait un grand talent dans la musique
n'a qu'à pas pu exploiter son talent que
la maladie a pris deux concepts dessus
c'est super il ne me tape pas dessus ce
n'est pas super justement il peut être
cruel
il peut effectivement il peut exercer
sur -5 santé mentale tant mieux si vous
tue pas mais quand y tue il est hors la
loi mais je pense qu'on est en la loi
bien avant
alors muriel royal en continuant quand
il vaut mieux alors pour vous en fait
l'explication que vous donnez du crime
de bertrand cantat l'univers de la
passion est une tuerie par essence bien
sûr l'univers de la passion ça dépend
quelle passion et comme on l'apprend la
passion selon le christ s'est passé là
et heureusement et la passion selon le
christ effectivement du son oui même
musulman mais c'est fallu qu'il avait
choisi non mais bien sûr nous est-ce que
ça non s'il restera c'est tout ça je
pense qu'il a droit une rédemption
j'ai vraiment envie que bertrand sorre
et consorts et qui sort de prison
maintenant dire que marie était
responsable de sa mort avec lui que
c'est la passion et l'amour qu'ils ont
tué non l'amour n'apporte pas la mort ou
alors c'est une erreur absolue
je vais pas dire jamais
mais ça c'est quelque chose qui est
important est que quand on s'entend
hubert félix thiéfaine qui liront jeter
barreau mon ami nous t'attendons dehors
honte à voler ton amour mais qui lui a
volé son [__] d'amour
marie est morte sur ses coûts dans un
visage tuméfié
il a laissé mourir dans son lit alors
qu'il aurait éclaté les secours c'est un
manque de compassion terrible moi j'ai
grandi où ce mot n'existe pas sans
empathie et sans compassion et là il y
en a pas eu donc c'est la part du
monstre moi je ne condamne pas la part
du monstre se veut que bertrand s'en
sortent se veut que christina s'en
sortent et ses enfants marie elle est
morte elle s'en sortira plus albert
dupontel bonsoir pardon pour commencer
de ne pas avoir eu le temps de voir
votre film je le regrette mais je peux
vous dire que j'en ai déjà beaucoup
entendu parler et en bien alors comme ça
vous êtes vilain vous nous avez fait des
frayeurs vous êtes arrivé en retard mais
vous êtes vilain dans ce film est est ce
que ce ne serait pas par hasard un tout
petit peu jeudi un poil autobiographique
nous montons du tout bon donc ce qui
veut dire que vous êtes investi dans un
rôle qui vous plaisait de créer en fait
ce vilain c'est quelle est l'origine de
cette histoire que vous mettez à l'écran
aujourd'hui nous invite sur un film et
catherine frot d'accord alors pari
réussi apparemment catherine frot qui
est paraît-il est une formidable
partenaire pour vous comment est ce que
vous avez pu faire j'allais dire pour
être est le partenaire devant la caméra
et en même temps réalisateur donc
derrière la caméra c'est ça doit être un
boulot demain non nous on était payé
tout simplement pardon en étant payé
tout simplement
ah c'est ça qui est motivant n'y avait
pas une envie artistique de création non
moi je mérite mon salaire ce qui peut
votre casse si vous voyez pas mis ce
film maintenant c'est pas vu le film je
vous ai dis parce que je vous en ai
demandé pardon publiquement
tout simplement parce que j'ai pas parce
que j'ai un métier justement moi aussi
compellent et voilà qui n'est pas de
faire fusionner d'ici et là vous le
devant et films avant d'inviter des gens
très bien merci je vous remercie
infiniment votre accueil
merci beaucoup bonne soirée à vous et
bonne soirée à vous aussi et merci de
nous donner l'occasion de vous avoir
salué très très rapidement l'occasion
c'était en fait le festival du film de
beauvais c'est amusant ce qui peut se
passer sur un plateau de télévision